[Music]
[Applause]
ever wonder like different choices
how we might end it up no
i like the hand we've been dealt
[Music]
watch me
you
me
together we were destined for something
great
why did i move here
i guess it was the weather
or the
i don't know that thing that magic
[Music]
but i thought we was trying to get out
of this [__]
you sounded more and more like
[Music]
we all love banks
give me a hand with these bodies
this cannot be traced back to me
champagne anyone
just sort of smash things
[Music]
it was great to kick today off with a
look back at just some of the seminal
moments of the last 25 years and what
better way to bridge our past and our
future than with a game that's graced
every playstation console grand theft
auto
it's been a privilege partnering with
rockstar games for many years now
and we're thrilled to open today with
the news that that partnership will
continue with playstation 5. it's now
just over a year since we began sharing
technical details of playstation 5.
but today's the day that we've been
looking forward to for years
when we get to show you just some of the
games that demonstrate our belief that
playstation 5 marks the biggest
generational transition our industry has
yet seen
the content we've curated for today's
event showcases how ps5 has inspired
developers to create new experiences
that are transformative in how they look
sound and feel
enough from me
we're gonna have the games do our
talking
a hero's just someone who doesn't give
up
your dad said that
he was right
now it's your turn
go be a hero miles
okay
let's do this
[Music]
is
so
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
yeah
you all right back
no way
it appears that the dimensions are
collapsing on one another if we cannot
get to
right the ship
i mean we can't be that far
they have found us ratchet
would steer this thing ask nicely
slow down please that's not listening
the dimensions are weakening
considerably
[Music]
how bad is it
well it is certainly not good
right
where are we
it's me
get off me ship
ratchet
we are too
late ratchet
who
[Music]
hi i'm marcus smith creative director at
insomniac games the entire studio is so
excited to be able to share with you a
first ever look at ratchet and clank
rift apart a brand new full-length
interdimensional adventure built from
the ground up for the playstation 5.
we're doing things we've never been able
to do before like use dimensional rifts
to be able to leap from planet to planet
nearly instantly or put ray trace
reflections on clank
all of our alien worlds are filled with
density and life previously unseen
plus ratchet's all new arsenal is more
exciting than ever thanks to the dual
sense controller's enhanced feedback
ratchet and clank are near and dear to
our hearts at insomniac and we can't
wait to share more with you in the
future but for now here's another look
did you see that
[Music]
oh
from above
[Applause]
or at least a very large octopus
i will never get used to that hey break
reality
i kind of wish he was doing a worse job
he might have more plans
that's what i'm afraid of
oh
that's all of them
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
wow
foreign
[Music]
so
making games used to be about these
constant trade-offs between the artistic
vision and technical limitations with
ps5 we're not going to be burdened like
that we're going to be able to realize
our artistic vision a lot better it's
got a ton of horsepower which is very
easy to unlock and it's a machine that's
really easy to develop on the ps5 will
present a paradigm shift as to what
players will come to expect from gaming
will let us tell stories make worlds
create gameplay that i think will truly
captivate the player and really supplies
quite a few people please take a look at
this new franchise for worldwide studios
coming exclusively for playstation 5.
over and over i relive my first moments
on this alien planet
the crash
the attack
my death
the crash
the attack
my death
trapped in this endless cycle
even death
is no escape
each time i awake this planet seems
somehow
different
[Music]
is it changing
this world is becoming part of me
infecting my mind
my memories
the longer i spend here
the more i can feel my sanity slip away
[Music]
but i cannot lose
hope
my only choice is to keep fighting
to keep looking for answers
my only hope is to break the cycle
before the cycle
breaks
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to london
[Applause]
destructions
[Music]
this is
no
vain again
[Music]
again
hello everyone my name is josh greer and
this is my brother mike we're from ember
lab a small team with a background in
film and animation
and we're very excited today to share
with you the first look at our new game
it's a story full of adventure and charm
that has themes in personal growth and
redemption so please enjoy
[Music]
i know you are kind
you sense the power that flows through
this land
yet
you do not fully understand it
driven by the belief that you can help
these troubled spirits
[Music]
but
you cannot hide your weakness from me
[Music]
you
have no power here
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you ever feel like you're just waiting
for a sign
to do that thing you've always meant to
do
sometimes i feel like i'm just standing
on the edge of doing great things
but something's holding me back
maybe it's just nerves
maybe it's the fear that
i'll never be as good as what i imagine
when i'm still just standing on the edge
but if we've got nothing else to lose
[Music]
might as well jump
[Applause]
this is
[Music]
this is the only way
and when we
go
[Music]
hi i'm lorne lanning and i'm here to
share with you a game that i've been
dying to make
it's an emotionally engaging story where
rescuing is rewarding failure is
devastatingly hilarious and the memories
should last you a lifetime take a look
you are no longer a slave abe
they believed trusted followed and it
led them here
you may have escaped
the murderous blades
for the fate of your entire people
[Applause]
is up to you
m
you see things others can't
hear threats others don't
fight
when others won't
[Music]
it's up to you to save tokyo
uh
[Music]
it's
crime
[Music]
these things
for free
[Music]
uh
so
it was always going to end like this
all your hard work
all your sacrifice
only sped up the process
[Music]
and now you find yourself alone
only death awaits
[Music]
hack and abrac here from iowa
interactive
in hitman 3 agent 47 is back for his
most intimate and professional contract
in his entire career
this is also the dramatic conclusion
for the world of assassination trilogy
[Music]
i'm so proud to be here to present a
little glimpse of the gameplay where
1847 is on top of the world
in dubai
enjoy
[Music]
my
wow
[Music]
so
um
[Music]
uh
what's up everyone i'm zion williamson
of new orleans pelicans here we go the
first ever teaser for nba 2k 21 y'all
are not ready for this
i ain't trying to break you down but for
real you might as well give up now i
think you got a chance but i don't see
how got a real tight grip when i hold
that crown i'm the first one in and the
last one out whoever owns the place
for your life
[Music]
amazing
a very recently discovered species
entirely unique to this island
oh this one's lively beautiful seed
patterns
[Music]
oh and it's tasty too
welcome to the island of bug snakes
[Music]
is
my invitation is open come join me on
the island oh
[Music]
liz
i am i was trying to carry a lamp with
my weeny hands but i dropped it and uh
now the town's on fire oh
again
[Music]
um
hi everyone thank you for being with us
today for this very special event
but before we get to the end of the show
i have something very near and dear to
me
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
desu is a negan first person shooter
about rival assassins locked in a time
loop this is our unique vision what
arcane is all about
freeform immersive gameplay
a surreal player driven story smashed
together
want to see some stylish action check
this out
[Music]
hello cult my predecessor has been
pronounced guilty of treason he is to be
shot on sight and forth in perpetuity
your assistance is appreciated and
mandatory the real party doesn't start
until he's dead
she is not making this easy
it's cold
[Music]
good morning black reef
another day another death
[Music]
for everyone else on this island this
place is paradise
a never-ending party
where hunting me is the main attraction
and no matter how i try to escape
they always cut me down
but i'm once dubbing [__]
[Music]
every loop i'm learning a little more
piecing together the puzzle
there's eight targets
and they all gotta die before midnight
there's just one little snag
[Music]
you thought it was going to be easy
julianna blake
black reef's protector and a real pain
in my ass
she may kill me a million times but
eventually inevitably
i will
break
this
[__]
loop
[Music]
there you go
i don't like watching you die
i like killing you
there's a difference
[Music]
long ago a young girl went with her
mother to pick berries for her father
it was hard at work
but the forest greeted them with a dark
cold silence
the bush is empty
yet determined to find the berries the
rascal broke free of mother's grasp and
vanished into the trees
mothers worried cries faded fast as the
girl ran on over vine under branch
and into the forest
what is it with that creepy story
it's just a local tale
you're really into that stuff
quit being so paranoid
no no friendly friendly
who are you
who sent you
come on
they're coming who is
[Music]
so
[Applause]
chris sorry ethan
why
[Music]
what is that
freedom
our freedom
[Music]
oh
the old ones
perished a thousand years ago
their great cities
turned to graves
and their place
came new life
[Music]
the new dangers
i must find a way to stop it
or it will get worse
and worse
[Music]
until it destroys us all
there's nothing i wouldn't do to save
this world
no depth i won't explore
[Music]
no secret i won't unlock
no barrier i won't cross
[Music]
this mission is mine alone
if i falter
if i fail
there won't be anyone left to stop
what's coming
[Music]
but whatever comes
i will be ready
on behalf of the entire team at gorilla
we're happy to share the first look at
horizon forbidden west we're continuing
earlier story as you move west to a far
future america to brave a beautiful but
dangerous frontier massed with
mysterious new threats get ready to
explore distant lands ravaged by massive
storms and take on new powerful machines
as you return to the majestic world of
verizon stay tuned for much more we
can't wait for you to get your hands on
it
i think there's a lot to look forward to
for the community i think fans are gonna
be really pleased
as a game designer and storyteller this
is incredibly exciting we're talking a
whole new generation of ideas and
experiences that we can create for the
player no matter where they are no
matter who they are
new experiences like we've never had
before more iconic interesting
characters more atmospheric immersive
worlds for players to explore we want to
wow players respect the unexpected and i
for one can't wait you can't wait we
can't wait to share them with you it's
so exciting incredibly exciting it's
really about learning
as a developer that's an amazing feeling
so
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
we hope you've enjoyed the first glimpse
of our future today
you've seen our most striking console
design yet
and you've seen games that can only be
enjoyed with the full range of
playstation 5's features and power
at playstation we believe in
generational transitions and we put
years of work into making them happen we
want you to enjoy the unique benefits of
moving from one generation to the next
thank you for joining us
we're launching later this year and we
have tons more to share
welcome to playstation 5.
[Music]
but whatever comes
i will be ready
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
okay get ready